yo I'm
so proud of your mom and I me too Beth
and I years
ago and just starting to settle back in
now
healthwise we do we were both heavily
infested with mold and Mercury yeah
Mercury from different things um but the
mold from the houses that we had lived
in and we're
both exhibiting
symptoms different symptoms because
because it hits you different ways right
but like yo guys in Los Angeles in one
year no exaggeration if you count hotels
in
airbnbs we
moved 15 times in one year calendar year
yeah this counts six places with
leases yeah there was there was one
point where I had a lease we technically
were living in four places I don't I
don't even know how you guys got out of
all that still it's crazy Health it was
just Health a and and the the places we
moved into didn't
want we were like hey we just had the
mold tested is through the roof and they
were like we'll let you out of the lease
you just can't say anything about the
mold but who would we say it to we
didn't know the next people coming in
yeah absolutely but we were we've been
good and sick and it's why we moved
around a lot and we finally have found
we've now
moved into a place we're moving in now
that's here in Vegas that is when we
were looking in Vegas in
2020 we drove into this neighborhood and
we were
like this is where we would want to live
dream of all dreams right and um we are
in that place right now we moved
in I this past couple weeks yeah so and
so much of it is is um has to do with
the people who are listening to this
podcast and people come to our shows so
thank you all so much but super [__]
cool man to finally get settled in
somewhere and feel especially after so
much and for those of you by the way I
would love to hear from any of you who
have had any mold stories of your own
but guys I will tell you something man
there was one night and your mom was
really sick oh yeah she had she had she
was exhibiting the worst symptoms for
sure well dude I was gone three days out
of the week at least I got reprieve
right you got you had a little reset
when you went when you left the house yo
dude there was one night I for I don't
know if I ever told you this the night I
moved her was out of there out of where
out of that I'm not going to say the
name of the street of the house but out
of that house W for the street name sure
yeah okay
um I came home and she had she had
developed dude this yellowish
gray Hue on her skin well she just look
sick and I came home and
she she
was we started she was just a little
erratic we both were erratic in that
house right she started punching the
walls and yelling at the house it was
almost like and neither one of us knew
what it
was but we had an idea maybe right and
um she started punching the walls and
yelling at the house and yelling at the
house W and I said hey she said yeah I
said go get in the car mhm we're never
coming back yeah she was like what do
you mean I said go get in the car we're
never coming back yeah and we talked to
the mole people who were like I was like
I want to go get my stuff and they were
like treat it like a fire anything you
bring from there that has the mold
spores will get into everything else
yeah guys we we you lived in the same
pair of pants that was sweatpants Jacob
wolf for we were both near 50 when this
happened
yeah and all the things we had
accumulated over our life mhm all of my
memorabilia anything that I had picked
up from a show from college anything up
until that family pictures gone yep I
have zero of it I don't have any of the
clothes I don't and I'll tell you and
same with your mom no books no the
pictures are in storage like all the all
the the the sentimental stuff is in
storage and we're just figuring out how
how to clean it out yeah but I will tell
you what a great lesson it honestly as
traumatic as it was do you know what it
both your mom and I over covid were like
yeah no big deal yeah it was It was kind
of nuts the
because we
had we had realized and figured out
because of the mold and because we had
to get rid of everything yo dude I
walked out of that house naked
I walked out of that house naked and put
new clothes on and got in the car that
is crazy I I to go back in there I had
to put a hazmat suit on you remember
that I had to get naked in the backyard
and put a [__] hazmat suit on and
walk through that is insane but I will
tell you what it taught
me it's just stuff yeah it's just
materialistic stuff none of it is
important and at the end of the day what
was important was that you guys were
health and safe when your mom and I
walked out of that place and I told her
I go leave everything get in the car
we're not coming back here we got in
that car and we drove to a
hotel and there was like a sense of calm
right uh about a day or two later it you
know after your you know whatever
self-pity or you go through the emotions
stuff like that yeah I
realized I don't miss any of that stuff
it's just stuff just stuff all of a
sudden sentimental stuff is still kept
just stuff all the wedding pictures all
the photo album we did not keep all the
sentimental stuff no no dude we got rid
of tons of memorabilia and tons of
sentimental stuff that we had picked up
over the years through things that were
important we kept family pictures period
yeah and we only kept this family
pictures that hadn't been digitized yeah
anything that was
digital we could get rid of right but we
get it but it re made me realize what
was important and what was important was
me and your mom 100% your health is the
most important thing at the end of the
day no matter no matter what it is like
if we had to move out of this house
because it was due to our health and I
had to leave all of my shoes I have this
again this not a humble brag this is
more like admitting to a problem I have
thousands of dollars yeah in shoes at my
house problem oh it's a problem yeah
yeah yeah thousands of dollars in shoes
at my house Y and if it was either and
it was either stay in there and not feel
good or leave and get better and it's
for me and Iman I'm leaving the shoes
I'm getting out I'll sell the shoes do
whatever yeah but the health is the most
important thing at the end of the day we
I didn't sell anything well right you
didn't have any valuable shoes I would
have sold my stuff people just get to go
through and pick I did yeah t-shirts I
would pick a lot of graphic teas yeah
yeah yeah so many good graphic T's over
the years had to go and jackets you know
the you know maybe the craziest thing
you know the thing that I miss the most
and have thought of the
most out of all the belongings
wait give me a hint I want to try and
guess this yeah yeah give me a hint is
it something I know what it is I mean
yeah you know them okay know them well I
mean it's not a person but like it
sounds like you have multiple of them or
it's a pair of something it okay it was
something that I had still had from
Seattle
oh something you would still had from
M all like fairly normal stuff or like
uh was it like comedy memorability you
weren't in Seattle for Fairly normal
what am I talking about
yeah I I don't know it was my pair of
Doc Martins oh the original docs mhm the
on from like 95 in 9 I bought them in 90
I did buy them in
94 and things are older than me yeah I
had gotten them resold a couple times
but that leather was soof you L those
shoes oh my God you wore those
everywhere well they symbolize a lot to
me it's for can I take a guess sure kind
of symbolize you you never want to
forget where you came from like like
you've worn those you wore those
throughout all the trials and
tribulations for your comedy career
raising kids meeting Mom doing all that
it was a symbol kind of of like like to
never forget what you've been through
and where you started and where you are
they were my only pair of shoes for a
long time oh okay oh until you got that
pair of shoes when you were on they were
my only pair of shoes man you know and
so they seen a lot and so yeah yeah it
was uh that may be the the thing that
but but I understand that at the end of
the day dude just docks yeah who [__]
cares just shoes who cares yep I I um
yeah what a weird time that was dude
what a weird time yeah it was a weird
time and
annoying oh my God I had to move you
guys in and out of so many places and
they all had were three levels and they
all had a lot of stairs
God after like the last after like the
like the I I don't remember what number
it was but after that every time you
guys text me I was like I'm working or
I'm busy I was like I'm not I can't I
can't do it cuz I also there was a part
of me in the back of my head I was like
are they staying there just because it
had happened so many times I wasn't
wishing it upon y'all but like I was
like just track record this is probably
going to happen again like it was it was
a lot I moved them in and out of
probably out of the
15 10 or 11 yeah something like that 10
or the boys had to help out too came to
with that onent Heights um yeah I called
in a lot of help cuz I was like yo I'm
tired I need some help they've made me
do this 1000 times it was a [__] show
but we made it happen we're here man now
man we made it
happen oh yeah hey man hey
man oh yeah hey man hey
man